cannabis consumption lounges are inching
closer to becoming a reality here in Las
Vegas Victoria Saha explains how they
can now move on to the next step in the
process
it's been nearly a year since the Nevada
cannabis compliance board hope 2022
would be a Target goal for opening
lounges where you could consume
marijuana that goal now closer to
becoming a reality applications are now
open for dispensaries to apply for a
consumption lounge with non-refundable
fees of up to one hundred thousand
dollars honestly it's going to be the
best thing Maxine funsum is the director
for Las Vegas Cannabis tours helping
tourists experience the recreational use
of marijuana she says currently tourists
don't have a designated place to smoke
they come here to indulge and this
there's no way to smoke so yeah
uncomfortable and it's you know takes
the fun and the buzz I suppose out of
you know coming here because a lot of
them come here specifically just to get
high we've partnered in with Planet 13
which is the world's largest dispensary
and uh they've already got their menu
set their pricing where they're going to
be putting their consumption Lounge you
have until October 27th to apply and it
must be done through the excela Cannabis
customer portal Victoria Saha eight news
now the state estimates as many as 40 to
45 retailers would apply for on-site pot
lounges that would bring in an estimated
4.5 million dollars only 20 applications
will be chosen in a lottery process